oh
what's up
we doing it again
live recording
of riffing with griffin
let's do it
[Music]
alright ladies and gentlemen
welcome back once again to yo
absolutely favorite podcast
[Music]
welcome back
[Music]
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome back to ripping
with
griffin and i'm doing it live once again
uh monday september 6
noon time here we are
nobody's here yet in the chat but we
doing it um i just want to say thank you
for being here i want to talk about um
i i saw 10 rings we're going to talk
about that and my love affair with asian
movies
uh we're going to talk about this
fentanyl overdose of a couple of people
that i know
um what else we're going to talk about
reverend griffin
um what else oh and then i filmed a
commercial and i want to tell you about
the technology that was on set at this
commercial so it was uh it was actually
pretty amazing
pretty amazing
so
you know also look out for that too uh
and we're all gonna do all this right
here live
on riffing with griffin
as always
you know i'm here doing it you know so
sometimes i do it live he's like you
know i was traveling and all this kind
of stuff so it's like it's hard to like
get episodes together and then i've been
doing like a lot of king and the sting i
don't know if you guys have seen me on
that and so like that takes up time you
know and then i'm starting this other
podcast and look out for that on
september 15th it's called jen to jen
with my buddy uh matthew espinoza
um oh man you know what i just realized
i didn't get this ready wait i gotta you
know i gotta
i'm doing this live so for you people
listening right now uh thanks for being
here
uh you know i appreciate i appreciate
that for you people listening you know
you're not you didn't listen live but
you're here you know so i appreciate you
guys being here for that that that's you
know
you know you still the people that like
only like audio and you know i'm all
about that too so
you know what i mean you know we do it
we do what we got to do when we do it
and so it is what it is
it is what it is my friends
hello darkness my old friends
um you know that i don't know what to i
don't know what to even say about that
but you know it like i say it is what it
is um
yes so i went to new york you know i
went to new york it's funny i got i got
to do this live like i forgot to like
set up my screen capture you know so
if it sounds like i'm trying to like
stall it's because that's exactly what
i'm doing but you know when you do it
live what are you supposed to do you
know it's like
sometimes i hate being a one-man show
but my guy wiggy's out of town he went
to seattle to visit his family so he
can't really you know he can't really be
here for this part right here so you
know but it is what it is like i say you
know but i mean i can get it done i'm
doing it right now and it's going to
come out great and we're all going to be
like oh i can't believe griff did that
on the fly
griff did that on the fly look how he
did that you know so
yeah let me see boom
oh no no this isn't the one i want hold
up guys
i gotta fix it we want oh it's this one
yes
yes
yes okay
uh
i did it i did it i did
it okay let me turn the auto live back
on boom all right so then i cuz i want
to show you
oops not there see i'm just i'm
completely messing up and thank you chad
for being here i see all you guys
what's up y'all good uh thanks for being
here thanks for supporting the show i
always appreciate that
um
you know
it's uh
you know it's it's you know i i saw
somebody i was in new york and this uh
after the show this guy came up to me
and he was like
yo man i really appreciate your your
podcast it really helps me it got me
through and and i was like oh man really
that's dope you know what i mean it's
like when people say that kind of stuff
to you you know you you think to
yourself damn well this is why i do it
you know what i mean this is why i do it
so
because sometimes i feel like i don't
want to do it anymore you know what i
mean i don't i i feel like that if i'm
just being honest with you guys
sometimes you know it's like you look at
other podcasts especially ones of my
friends and i'm like wow they're so big
and successful am i ever gonna be like
that and then i just feel like you know
you start to compare and you really
shouldn't do that so you know i stopped
doing that but anytime i sort of feel
like that the universe sends me somebody
and they're like hey
um
you know somebody's like i really enjoy
your podcast please keep doing it or
like it really helped helps me or that
kind of stuff and i go you know what i'm
you know it is what it is i'm i'm doing
you know i'm i'm doing what i need to do
you know what i mean
um
so that that so that's like really
that's the thing that really makes me go
okay i i'm doing something right so you
know
all right let me go to i'm trying to go
to instagram so i could talk about this
new podcast that i'm that i'm doing so
you guys can see who i'm talking about
uh where the hell is he
you know i can't i can't ever find this
is why you have to have like a jamie you
know what i mean
you know it's so annoying dude
all right here's the guy so
let's go back okay so i'm doing this new
podcast it starts on september 15th
and it's it's it's with my dude i've
known him for like eight years now
you know his name is matthew espinoza
guys this is this is the dude okay you
know he's got like a bunch of followers
he's big on youtube so it's called
gender gen so he's gonna he's a young
guy going to teach the old guy about
young guys stuff and i'm gonna teach him
about old guy stuff we're gonna have
guests from different genres and
different things like that and you know
we're gonna figure it out and so look
for that on september 15th gen 2 gen
okay
all right here we are so look you know
what also let me uh while i'm doing this
i'm going to go ahead and tweet out that
um that i'm live right now
you know what i mean let's do that boom
so i'm tweeting live so we know what's
going on i know you people listening on
like spotify and apple music and all
this kind of stuff you guys are probably
like what the hell is he doing why am i
listening to him working on his stuff
live but it is what it is so over here
all right so i got some bad things to
talk about and i have some good things
to talk about just you know how my mood
is and how i get about certain things
but first thing
so i had a light week like i said i went
to new york and it was crazy because my
flight was canceled
because of this major floods that
happened in new york i know you guys did
you guys see some of the the imagery
from the floods in new york i mean it
was like armageddon you know i i didn't
even know what to i don't even know what
to think about that stuff that was going
on in new york they you know they were
talking about
uh you know the the subways were flooded
and that kind of stuff you know it was
it was actually pretty pretty bananas i
don't know if you guys saw that it was
you look at this from three days ago 46
dead you know they i mean this is like
some crazy
i mean that's some crazy stuff going on
right there you know look at all that
stuff like you know look at that one
right there like the cars are underwater
you know the streets were flooded the
subways were flooded you know they were
they were showing like the subways being
all
being all flooded it was like it was
crazy look at that can you see it good
there you go you know it was i was like
damn this is crazy
and so then the flight was canceled i
was supposed to go in on a red eye so i
could do some press in in the morning
time you know that's what i'm talking
about later preston the morning time and
then it was um
so i got on an early morning flight and
then i flew into new york and as we're
flying in the the uh the captain's like
it's a beautiful day in new york 75
degrees and i was like damn
i was like damn what happened i thought
there was like floods and stuff you know
and oh thank you for the super chats
guys i just saw him right now
uh ken thank you ken and thank you uh
andre or adrie or whoever that is and
you know for you people that are like
again listening you know you gotta
listen you gotta check me out when i'm
doing it live so you can support the
show you know and guys uh please also
check speaking up please check out my
patreon i'm gonna start doing more
things on the patreon i know i keep
saying this but i'm thinking about doing
like a morning or evening kind of like
quick you know it's like 10 15 minutes
like hey this is what's going on today
kind of the
thoughts from griffin uh daily
not daily but you know maybe like three
times a week on patreon and then like a
higher tier is going to be like if you
want to play video games with me eric
griff on on my twitch channel eric
griffin gaming i'm gonna start doing a
tier and i'm gonna make that tier for
that so look out for that so if you
wanna if you want to support me on
patreon please check that out so
anyways
you know i get into new york and it's
like a beautiful damn day you know what
i mean
and i was like damn well what happened
to
what happened to this like you know i
thought i thought
the way it was looking on tv the way he
was looking on the commercials man you
were i needed to build an ark and start
collecting animals that's what it looked
like in uh new york but it actually
turned out to be but then my show was
terrible you know i think it's like i
think with this they just did this mask
mandate now in new york so a lot of the
places not masks um vaccine mandate so
it's like you can't get in unless you're
vaccinated
and then you can't and then you had the
floods and then people are still
uncertain about what's going on with
this delta variant all this kind of
stuff and so and i'm not a huge i guess
you know new york's a tough sell all
right i just want to let you know it's a
tough sell
because i think it's a huge metropolitan
city there's so much stuff going on the
club i was at caroline's literally
a half a block up the street hugh
jackman was doing a play
so it's like
that's where it's right on broadway so
you're just like
you know i i'm not that draw like if i
was at say the seller
with like seven or eight other comics if
you're in town if you lived there you
could be like oh i can go sierra griffin
and i could see these other people too
and there's a chance that there's some
huge pop in as opposed to coming to
watch me for an hour in a city like that
is different because there's so many
clubs there's like eight clubs and it's
like so
unless you're like a huge draw it's hard
to get like fill the comedy club up you
know
you know what i mean and it's like and i
tried to i i paid for instagram i had i
did all these things man and it's just
like
i don't know it's it's a it's an ego
shot i'll tell you that right now every
week is different so next week i'm gonna
be in denver so look out for me there
will be a denver comedy works actually
this thursday friday and saturday so if
you're in the denver area please check
me out there i'll be at the denver
comedy works denver comedy works you
know i guess this is a good time to even
do my own my own commercial for for
myself right i should be like hey come
check me out yeah i never i should talk
about this more you know even if you're
listening to this later later you know
you should go to my schedule at
ericgriffin.com
schedule i'm still working on this dumb
website you know
but there you go guys i got so i just
did the caroline's i will be at the
denver comedy works 9th through the 11th
then i'm coming to boston the 23rd
through the 25th addison improv so look
those are some of my dates right there
so make sure you guys uh make sure you
guys check that out so you know but i
know denver is going to be a lot better
because it's more of a comedy town and
they're used to like you only watch one
comic it's not a showcase type of thing
on the weekends so you know that is what
it is so
all right
good things first i did this ibm
commercial you know i haven't done a
commercial in a while but i've actually
uh i booked this commercial i did it and
it was the craziest thing like the shoot
the commercial shoot was like
um
it was
it was it was a weird like you know i'm
trying to look at the chat too guys let
me let me actually
let me actually
pop the chat out so i can look at it
like full screen there we go now i have
it right here on the screen uh there we
go so um yeah i got texas dates coming
up all the uh the um addison improv
first through the third in october so
so okay so you get on set and then i'm
looking at the schedule now i've done
commercials before and even when you do
like one
one scene in a commercial or or whatever
the commercial that little moment in the
commercial is it usually takes all day
to shoot so they were actually doing
three commercials in one day
like right at this one location so i was
like wow this is like a really intense
it's probably gonna be real quick so
when i finally get on set like you know
getting dressed you know everything that
it takes like that's the longest part of
the day is getting yourself ready to go
so then
i get on set right
and
the um
the uh what do you call it the
okay
we finally get on set and then there's
like a robot okay
there's like this robot camera that is
the thing and i'm gonna i i this isn't
the actual thing but this is sort of
what it looked like okay i'm gonna show
you right now this is sort of what it
looked like it looked it looked like
that thing right there okay see that it
was like the camera was connected to
this robot arm and there was one guy
behind a computer just like this is
looks on the screen but the camera
wasn't even like that the camera was
like a long cylinder tube like a really
like it looked like a like what the
alien like if somebody said they got
attacked by aliens they got kidnapped by
aliens this is the thing they would use
that's what it looked like because it
looked like an anal probe like a long
okay so we had this long camera and then
they were setting up so the guy was like
all right this is position one he put
something in the camera boom boom boom
the computer and then it was like this
is position two and then they whipped it
around you know and it was like you know
i had to like hold the phone up it was
like in the commercial i'm holding a
phone and then it pulls away from the
phone and i say some lines you know what
i mean
and um
you know and that's how they did it so
then when we started going man we did
like 17 takes like this
it was like action then we did it and
you know and then the guy was like all
right position one again
and the camera went back and then it was
like just we did it over and over and
over again you know it was called a
cobra the name of the camera the setup
was a cobra and i thought to myself you
know what my first thought was there
goes somebody's job like i just thought
well there it is right there here's
technology like making people that want
to be in the entertainment business like
if you want ever wanted to be a camera
guy so now they only had two guys
working now usually they have like
there'll be three people working a
camera you got the lens person you got
the
and then there's a focus guy so they
still had the focus guys so there's
always somebody who's like looking at
like they have like a little like an
ipad looking type thing and they got
like this little focus wheel on it
and as the camera moves this person is
keeping everything in focus i mean
that's standard on any set
and i feel like that guy's gonna get
they're gonna take him out eventually
too
but it was like so then there was no
like usually also when you do like a
scene in a movie or tv show whatever
like and say there's camera movement you
know so the camera the the people move
in and then they go okay back to one and
that's usually what takes a long time
the back to one is like oh everybody's
got to move the camera and you know all
these three people are helping the
camera guy and everybody's moving into
place and then they have to get all set
up again and that usually what takes
forever with this thing it was like back
to one and then the thing was like
boom and it was ready to go then they
were like okay action and so we got like
way more done faster but at the same
time i was like damn there goes people's
jobs man
you know what i mean i was
like i mean it was like and then the
thing though was like and like you said
i see in chat somebody says they can
recreate the shot perfectly and it's
like yes
so on one side i see the benefit it's
like you got this thing that can just
write you know here's the perfect angle
we need or there's some particular shot
you want and then the thing can like
move in different angles and it could be
and like you can get all kinds of
different things and then they can do it
and they can recreate it exactly so
that part of it's great and the other
side of it is like well damn what if you
always wanted to work a camera because
there are people sometimes i ask
somebody on set and i go hey did you or
do you have aspirations to be the guy
holding the camera or do you want to do
that and a lot of times you see people
go like no this i love this i love
working with the lenses and you know and
being a part of the team like that and
you just go damn i mean they're going to
be this is this is the future is
happening right now i mean even when you
think about doing like sitcoms and they
have these three camera sitcoms i have a
feeling that the future is going to be
the director is actually going to be
sitting at the computer terminal with
somebody working the computer terminal
and they're going to be like okay action
and then the cameras are going to do
predetermined things and movements and
then you know there's not going to be
this whole crew of people working the
cameras uh so i don't know man
it was uh it was a pretty
pretty wild man it was pretty
you know i was like damn this is i mean
the future is here you know what i'm
saying the future is here
um
all right so
actually before i before i go on with my
what i'm going to talk about next is um
you know this is actually a pretty
important topic i'm going to talk about
next so and this actually works out
perfectly for this week because this
episode is sponsored by
betterhelp
betterhelp.com griffin uh for the
discount and but i do want to talk about
uh
therapy and getting professional help um
it's important
um i i i stand by therapy but one of the
things that you have to understand is
therapy is not going to solve your
problems and this is a really important
point all right it's not going to solve
your problems and you may not even feel
better
if that's the point of you going to
therapy and you think well i'm not going
to feel better and they're not going to
solve no because that's not really the
point the point of therapy is to help
you pinpoint
why you feel the way you feel and help
you attack that help you to find some
coping mechanisms to further
you know make your life better and more
fulfilled because we have these things
that are holding us back
there's a lot of things that hold back
happiness and and you know there's so
many things man there's depression
stress anxiety you have anger you have
family conflicts you might have trauma
you might you know you have trouble
sleeping self-esteem issues and
you know you need to talk to somebody
and better help is a great service for
this uh it's convenient it's
professional
um you know
there's so many people that are now
joining betterhelp they've added like 50
million new uh
therapists and it's not it's not a
self-help this is a licensed therapist
in a comfortable environment in front of
your computer at your home or wherever
you can find a quiet location and i
really do highly recommend it because so
many people out there are struggling
over the last two years the the world
has gone upside down and we're
struggling with it we're not not
everyone is handling it and even the
people that you think you're handling it
we were already holding on by a thread
and then we added this whole thing this
global pandemic that just pushed us over
the edge and you might have trouble with
ways to figure out how to cope with this
and people are turning to alcohol and
drugs and i'm just suggesting if you're
feeling that what you're feeling a
certain way please reach out and get
some help and better help is a great way
to do that too so look i want you to
start living a happier life today as a
listener you'll get 10 off your first
month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com griffin join over 1
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health that's
betterhelphelp.com for 10 off your first
month start living a better life
today
all right
um okay
all right guys i want to talk about
something tough to talk about right now
okay so wait let me get take this off
the screen right now
uh there we go
uh
all right guys so over the last couple
days when i was in new york i found out
that some people that i know
uh this comic fuquan johnson and like
two other people one of the another one
i know rico the thing is i actually
i actually help my friend i directed a
comedy sketch
a comedy sketch like a little five
minutes comedy sketch and i wanted to
get into directing so i said how
directed for you and two of these people
were in it and now they're both dead you
know they're both freaking dead
um
you know so the stories about food two
others die in a possible fentanyl
overdose
it's a fentanyl overdose you know and i
don't even know what the health fentanyl
was so i even like
i needed to look that up you know like
fentanyl some sort of synthetic
you know synthetic opioid you know and
it's super powerful
and people are odin on this all the time
and you know it's like how does fentanyl
affect your brain
uh you know you have extreme happiness
drowsiness nausea confusion constipation
sedation problems breathing
unconsciousness like i don't get it like
personally i don't get
i've never taken any kind of drugs like
this and so i don't understand the point
the point if because it doesn't seem
like there's anything good about this
you know
and then people overdose on this thing
all the time and apparently it's
happening more frequently than
they're even talking about they put it
with cocaine
and uh or other drugs and then it's like
if you i guess if you have too much or a
bad batch this is what happens so
apparently these four people and one of
my other friends is is in the hospital
still and who knows if she's gonna like
be the same you know
and how do i feel about this
you know
i'm triggered by this because i have
someone in my life who's an addict
you know and so this is just my
my i'm gonna give you my initial
thoughts what of it was i couldn't be
sad
i'm actually mad i was actually furious
about this
you know it makes me angry to think that
people are still overdosing on drugs
it's amazing to me that the people that
do drugs frequently think that they're
going to be the ones that are going to
beat drugs like oh well that happened to
those people it's not gonna happen to me
and
the when you see that and then when it
happens you kind of go i remember when
that dude from glee died the dude from
glee died of a heroin overdose in a
hotel room at a party or something like
that and it made me so mad to think like
i hope that all those people that were
there
just kind of like oh yeah this is what
the life is i hope they're still
suffering i hope they're still thinking
about it because it's like damn and it's
not their responsibility you know it's
just a layered issue because it's like
you know i'm talking about you have to
have some personal responsibility you
know but it's like that's why i don't
even like being around this kind of
stuff because i would take
responsibility like sometimes i don't
like hanging around people that like
like to get drunk and stuff because
let's say you're out at a bar or you're
at a bar with your buddies and i'm not
drinking and then everybody else is
drinking then i see one of my friends
who he has his car keys and he wants to
drive and i'm kind of like well it's not
my responsibility i just check out and
then my friend goes and kills six people
because he was drunk driving there's
gonna be something in me that's gonna be
like damn maybe i should have done
something so i don't even wanna put
myself in that position
i don't even want to put myself in that
position so it's like because then it's
like i would feel like i'm responsible i
would feel like damn i should have done
something and it's like so i don't i
don't like that you know what i mean
it's like
so
i heard about this and i was just like
and these people you know
they did drugs that wasn't the first
like i'd feel sad if it was like you
know you hear about somebody who went to
a party and for the first time they were
like i'll try cocaine and then you know
they tried that for the first time and
then they die
i mean that would make me feel like well
that's sad and i would be furious at
those people who like why would you give
somebody who's never done cocaine
cocaine you know whatever you know
that's just my rationale about it you
know but then when you hear about people
who like we're frequently doing drugs
all the time i knew about these guys
they i don't hang out with them because
of it i don't hang out with these people
i never did i don't like being in places
where people think it's okay to get
drunk and do drugs that's just not my
thing and then this happened you know
you're not getting cocaine and fentanyl
from cvs and there's a fda approval of
it and that's a whole other discussion
it's like
it's like uh
you know
should drugs be legal so then we can
like make sure that people aren't
getting a bad batch because here's the
thing these guys took apparently they
took one line and then like they died so
it's like whoever this drug dealer is
who has a bad batch of drugs he that
he's selling or she is selling to like
people there could be other people out
there right now there could be other
families that are shattered and ruined
because some guys just you know making
money and selling some bad stuff so we
we don't even know i mean there could be
an investigation we found out later that
20 people are dead from this batch of
cocaine fentanyl mix
you know what i'm saying so it's like
you know so when you're somebody that
thinks like oh i'm okay with drug you
know it's not gonna happen to me or i'm
good or like whatever your thing is
you know you don't know what these
people don't care about your health and
safety they only care about money
now listen addiction is tough
addiction is tough that [ __ ] gets a hold
of you and you have no control over it
you know you really have no control over
and that's that's and that's part of the
problem too it's not an excuse it just
is what it is because it's easy to say
like it's easy for someone like me who's
never taken drugs to be like man i ain't
never that's not gonna happen to me
because i have control of myself in that
way i'm never gonna put myself in that
position you know and it's like but some
people who are like now
they're so far in and they're an addict
but this is what i'm saying about
getting therapy and help if you are
someone that like you have to
self-medicate because you have no other
recourse you know a lot of these people
who like get hooked on drugs you know
the people that i know it's like damn
they got other stuff going on they got
these issues that they can't handle they
can't manage they got no other coping
mechanism so they self-medicate
some other people just starts with like
they just party they got impulse control
problems they just like i like to party
they like to be a free spirit and they
just like to go out go out and do their
thing and then and then sometimes bad
things happen there too
you know and so there's no right or
wrong way there's no like set laws
there's no like this is what happens if
you do a b will happen you know you
never know but the thing is it's like to
stay away from that kind of stuff
altogether i mean yeah that's the best
course of action but i know not
everybody's going to do that look and
there's a difference between people who
are just like yo i like to party because
i know people like that i know people
who are productive members of society
they go out on a friday night they get
blasted they're having fun and then you
know they're fine you know they just go
oh i'm never gonna do that again it's
not like a regular thing they're not
addicted to it you know there's
different levels of this man but even
someone like that you know you're like
yeah i did some cocaine at a thing i was
at a party and it's like you never know
what i'm saying is you just never know
here's somebody out here selling some
[ __ ] that's killing people man and it's
like you know it's like lives are now
irregularly damaged irregular well how
do knobs they're damn well you know the
word i'm trying to say i'm just i'm
upset right now so you just never know
you just never know and so
i don't know how to feel man i i
initially i was just like really upset
at them and i was mad at them you know i
really was
i really just was like damn
like what are you doing it's like you
why did you think that you were gonna be
the one that this was gonna be like not
gonna hit
why did you think that oh yeah i got you
know we're good i'm a professional drug
user type of attitude
and now three people are dead they're
dead
their families are just crushed
all because of
choices
so
it's tough
you know it's tough
it's tough and i don't know how to feel
about it
because when you look up these
statistics about fentanyl apparently
this is like
people are now coming out with their
stories now i know so many people are
like yeah i know four people who died of
this wiggy was on the episode last week
talking about his two friends that
overdosed i had to ask him if that was
like was that fentanyl related i mean
we're talking about dammit i just think
about that two weeks in a row now
five people are dead from drug overdose
and it's the same kind of thing they're
waking up and people are finding them
dead you know i mean other people are
finding them dead the next day and this
is like some kind of thing that's just
going around and man
look i know you're dealing with stuff i
know people are struggling and i know
it's a hard subject to talk about and
i'm just i'm just really sharing my
feelings about this right now you know
it's my podcast this is this is my world
so i can you know this is what i do
maybe some of you feel the same way as i
do or maybe some of you don't maybe you
guys are in the comments like going off
because you're not hearing what i'm
really saying or you know or you're
translating this to what you want it to
mean so you can like be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the comments i get it you
know i mean i just want i've done this
long enough now to get people's
motivation for being a [ __ ] in the
comments you know i mean i get that do
you all right but for the rest of you
we're just
trying to think about our feelings in a
vulnerable way
and it's like this is like been going on
for so long now
that it's like damn you know we kind of
let things go you know like people been
overdosing for 100 years maybe longer
who knows i'm just saying you know all
my life people are overdosing and you
know when it doesn't touch you you kind
of just kind of go well whatever you
know you just don't think about her you
don't think like man is this like a
serious problem and now here is like i'm
one degree away
and i you know from people now five
people are dead
in my immediate
circle of friends you know someone i
know knows people or i know the people
and
i don't know what we're gonna do as a
society or to like
you know fix this problem
you know
this this fentanyl is like
this sucker this this sucker is crazy
man
because
you know they got to throw the book at
these people these people that are
selling fentanyl and making it and you
know cutting it together with other
things
and they're not scientists you know this
ain't breaking bad you don't got some
chemistry teacher who's like you know
what we got to put just this amount
because if we don't it's going to kill
people these [ __ ] are just
trying to make stacks they don't care
they just they literally don't care
about you all they care about is your
money
and you know and they're out there
accessory to murder that's what it is
you know and
for what
for what
you know
you people that have done drugs is it
worth it
like is that feeling you feel worth it
i mean you tell me you know what do i
know
you know if you think it's worth it
it's like
i just i don't get it
because
to me i hear more stories about this
than anything else i hear more stories
about people who are now
because when you're an addict you're
always an addict so like you know now
you're an addict and now you're fighting
this addiction and then your whole life
is
and people in your life now have to be
dealing with your [ __ ]
i hate it
you know i hate it and so when i think
about these people that have died i want
to feel sorry and sad but i feel sad for
their families but i'm mad at them
i am it makes me mad i just feel like
what did you do
and why and look look
you know
uh
and i see people in the chat i know it's
like it's hard to like look
it's like
the excuse of these people are not an
addict it's hard to stop okay i get that
you know but i also have a valid feeling
of like man [ __ ] off
like look what you did you know like
look you know it's like
it's it's just such a tough thing it's a
tough it's such a tough subject it's
such a tough thing to deal with
and
i don't know my heart goes out to
all the people that were affected by
this and anybody else that's dealing
with
addiction
personally or if you're dealing with it
in your family i really
i really hope that you can heal and get
some help
uh all everybody that's involved because
take it from me as a person
who is like a family member of someone
this is hard it's hard man that's why i
get triggered when i hear these kinds of
things some people instantly are like oh
my god i'm so sad for them and uh you
know not me you know because i get
triggered because
i've been there i've seen i've been in
the middle of it where i know someone's
making a choice and they can make a
different choice
and then how sucky it is that now as the
loved one you got to be the one to make
hard choices that's the thing that
pisses me off that's what makes me
resentful you know it's like
let me tell you something when you love
someone you have a loved one and you
love them okay and then people tell you
and that person's an addict and then
everyone around you says
[ __ ] like you know you got to cut
them off you know you got to kick them
out you got to cut them off you got to
let them hit rock bottom
oh so easy to say that it's so easy to
be like oh yeah yeah let me just let me
just cut off this person that i love
deeply let me just put this person out
on the street or let me just be like you
know what i wash my hands of this person
that i love deeply you know and then and
then like something happens to them and
you act like i'm gonna be like well
you know i i tried no man that's hard
too
it's hard being in the person that's
dealing with somebody that you care
about that's an addict [ __ ] is hard man
it's hard it's so easy for people other
people to be like cut them off or you
know you got to do this but now i know
you do have to do that and i'm
acknowledging how hard it was i had to
work up to being a point of being like
i'm not giving you money i'm not doing
this uh you know i don't want to deal
with your nonsense anymore if you want
this relationship you have to like you
know
you know how much it takes you to get to
that point and then you become resentful
man you go you resentful because it's
like why do i have to be the bigger
person why do i have to be the one that
has to like you know deal with all this
stuff and you just have all these
feelings you know and then your
boundaries are challenged and that's the
thing man
it's about boundary issues and
it's just anyway my point is the whole
thing is tough the whole thing is tough
to deal with
you know it's just tough and it's like
what are we going to do as a society to
help curb this it's like because there's
so many layered issues like again let's
go over it like one it's like you're
making the drugs illegal and ain't doing
[ __ ] okay you ain't doing nothing to
help uh stop the drug problem so okay my
feeling is this is just my feeling make
make the drugs legal and then freaking
organize it you're still gonna have the
the illegal ones but now you make it
harder for them to do it because you
know you should be able to go to cvs
yeah let me get that cocaine uh let me
get a ice let me get arizona iced tea
and that cocaine fentanyl you know what
i mean and then but this now
this is a kind of mix you know it's not
gonna kill you and then we could track
it and then we could be like okay and
then
that money
there should be like syntax on it and
then that money is going towards drug
rehab drug help uh you know the
hospitals and all that kind of stuff to
like you know because it's like these
people are going to do this anyway so
like you know let's that's that's
benefit from it as a society to like
help people that want to get off the
stuff i mean it's crazy i don't know
that's just my thought you know what i
mean
i you know i look i'm not running for
office you know
so i don't know
say what you will about it on your own
you know whatever you think i'm just
giving my thoughts about it so you know
you have that side of it and then you
have the side of it that's like you know
it's an addiction it becomes an
addiction and people like you know they
selling their mama's tv to get the drugs
so you know there's an issue there how
do you stop that i don't think making
drugs illegal is stopping that i think
it's just that issue is still going to
happen so
therapy i think is another thing too
that's important for all of us i think
we got to get this stigma off the
therapy where people think that therapy
is like you know
man do you know how great it is like
don't you have a friend that you've ever
talked to and once once you did that
talking you instantly started to feel
better or you work something out that's
i'm telling you
the problem
with talking
is having to care about the other
person's feelings all right that is why
it becomes hard to talk to someone so
like in a relationship you love this
person
and it's hard to be like yo
you're doing something that's getting on
my nerves or i'm feeling this way i'm
having some personal feelings about this
without that other person now bringing
their own feelings into it like oh is
that because of me or or translating it
in this like they think it's like oh
well now you're making me feel like i
did something wrong you know what i'm
saying like you know when you're talking
to your girl or your guy and it's like
you just want to get some [ __ ] out and
they making it about them that's what
happens when you know the person that
you're talking to you know let me tell
you when you go to a therapist you don't
have to give a [ __ ] about this person's
feelings and i think that's great this
is just somebody you can bounce ideas
off of and they are a professional they
will be able to be like oh you know what
i'm pinpointing some things
uh that i recognize this pattern and it
could be because of this and then you
can take that information and do what
you want with it right
but the fact that you don't have to
worry about
this person's
feelings
like letting their feelings get into
your recipe into your soup
that's helpful
that is a super helpful thing so
i don't know
i don't know man
um
yeah i don't want to talk about this
anymore
it is what it is but like i say again
guys betterhelp.com griffin if you just
if you if you're on the fence about
getting therapy
uh
please
i'm telling you if you have insurance
get it there's also some cheaper
alternatives out there get it look for
it all right enough with that fun stuff
now
um i well fun and some serious topics
too about it too so
i saw
i went to a movie in new york for the
first time you know and i haven't been
to a movie in like over a year it was
like almost two years i think it was
like even before march of 2000
it was like a year and a half maybe a
year six months i have not been to a
movie
and i used to go to movies all the time
man
i loved that's my thing especially going
on the road i love going to movies so i
couldn't go to movies and then the kova
you couldn't go to movies it was like
what the hell you know
so i went to a movie
so i saw
the shangshi or i don't know how to say
it you know what i mean i hate when they
have names like this because then you
feel like you're racist if you can't say
it right
uh legend of the ten rings and this is
part of the mcu marvel universe this is
like phase four of the marvel universe
so this is no captain america no iron
man but what's going on
external externals or internal with the
eternals is coming out and i love the
trailers for that movie man but i want
to tell you about this movie i thought
this movie was fantastic okay i really
really enjoyed this movie
um
knows i mean
you know i'm trying not to do no spoiler
alerts uh spoilers i'm not gonna tell
you but i just liked it i liked the
fighting i liked the story i thought the
people
you know some of the acting was a little
corny but it was still very good you
know i i believed everybody
uh you know i believed them
you know it's like they do the the main
star i'm not gonna even try to butcher
their names
aquafina was funny
like you know michelle yao she's great
yeah she's always in those kung fu
movies she's great like michelle yeah i
was great like you know she's like now
she's like older so now she's like this
you know she's always like the old sage
kung fu woman you know what i mean she's
like a old grandma kung fu grandma so i
i really like her
but this was like i'm telling you
this was a really great movie you know i
thought it was great and then of course
you got to wait to the end you have to
watch the trailer i'm sorry you have to
watch the credits they got those marvel
end scenes they kind of teased some
stuff that's going on so you know that
it's in the marvel universe but you know
10 rings is about like you know it's
like it's just like the the infinity
stones the 10 rings are this powerful
uh
magic thing that you know this guy's had
for a thousand years and he's kept him
alive and he's like you know
uh he's just like this warrior warlord
and you know you know power corrupts and
you know
you find out his story and you know he
falls in love and he has some kids and
and it's just a story of uh you know
living up to ex living up to your
father's expectations uh you know living
living your own self and there's a lot
of concepts and things that go on in
this movie
that i think are like it was really good
and just just overall it's just a good
action movie too and i thought it was a
good marvel movie i thought that i
thought that this is like all right i i
can't wait to see him with the hulk or
whoever is going to be
in the marvel universe you know i can't
wait to see like how that plays itself
out so
you know look out for that
um i do i i give this a thumbs up and uh
go go watch this movie especially if
you're a marvel universe nerd i mean
there are worse movies in the marvel
universe that are important to the
marvel story i mean if you think about
it there were 22 movies
22 movies that led up to end game
and not all of them were good like that
first captain america was not good uh
that second thor was not good uh you
know it i mean the list goes on and on
and some of the like the second like the
avengers of age of ultron
get get rid of that one uh iron man
three like
let me just talk about some real quick
iron man three you know what don't make
any sense to me like i think iron man 3
you have to take it completely out of
the lexicon because you know why in iron
man 3 there was that power that could
heal people
like that would be very useful in
moving in the mcu like that little power
that was in um iron man 3 could have
healed tony stark like what happened to
it you know what i'm saying like when
he'd used the stones that power should
have healed him and he would have been
fine so they so you know and i hate
knowing that knowledge that that was in
there
uh you know that was in there like
i see somebody comments talking about
thor number three thor number three was
terrible okay the the dark elves one or
whatever no no that's the one i'm
talking about oh yeah that one was
terrible i didn't like that but it was
necessary for the story this is what i'm
trying to say as a collective the 22
movies
made end game and infinity war fantastic
so this is one of those movies that's
going to be in the new set of movies
that's going to lead up to something but
this one was pretty good it was pretty
good i really enjoyed it i really
enjoyed it
um i really enjoyed it now let me talk
about the controversial part of like or
this is not even controversial but
this is just my thoughts guys
my thoughts i'm speaking for me i ain't
speaking for you i'm not speaking for a
collective i'm speaking for me
there was a lot of you know we're on the
heels now of like black lives matter and
stop asian hate stop asian hate became
the new thing and so this movie comes
out and then there's this feeling of
like
people aren't gonna like this because
it's all asian or this kind of sentiment
was being put out there and i call
[ __ ]
i call [ __ ]
this was much to do about nothing in my
opinion all right
asian movies are great and they've been
great for 50 years
okay
bruce lee is one of the most beloved
action hero stars
of all time
the [ __ ] is dead he's been dead
for years and we still talk about bruce
lee
okay when i was a kid they had this
thing and listen
talking about cultural appropriation and
and the way things are portrayed to the
white masses or the the you know what i
mean and when i say white masses i mean
it's like for white television but we
all were watching it if black belt
theater is insulting i'm sorry okay my
apologies but i never once thought about
oh these are all asian this ain't right
no no i always was like oh this is great
the the five deadly venoms the shaolin
masters like there's so many great asian
starring movies these people weren't
even speaking english in the movie and
you still was like this is amazing
kung fu you add kung fu to anything and
it becomes amazing so this idea that
we're like anti-asian or that don't put
me in that
because you're just doing that because
you want to hear yourself talk i can't
stand that because this is ridiculous to
me man
jet li i i i used to buy every single
jetly dvd that's how much i loved jet li
romeo must die like all of those movies
were great
jackie chan jackie chan i love jackie
chan movies he was one of the first like
of these kind of like great kung fu
masters who would let himself get beat
up and it felt more real it felt like oh
man he's getting beat up and then you
know then he then he crossed over when
he they brought i remember when they
brought all he was already an
international superstar and then he
brought his movies over to the united
states and re-released them as new
movies and we were like whoa this is
great and then he then he started making
new movies and he's still making movies
the dude's 100 years old and he's still
doing his own stunts and making movies
so it's like shut up man
i don't want to hear it and it's just me
i don't want to hear it okay there is no
asian hate when you see when you see all
asians in the movie there is no
nothing where we're like oh i don't want
to watch this because these people are
asian nobody
no one i know thinks like that and i
think that this twitter
woke [ __ ] is just trying to play
that up to make it out so they can have
something to play up and talk about you
know yes are there people out there that
hate people yes okay but when i see that
i go what are you talking about i know
more people that love
anything that comes out of man korean
movies korean movies are some of the
best movies ever made and you know and i
wish that there wasn't the language
barrier and that's what stops us okay
that's what stops us
it stops us because it's like it's i
don't like reading my movies i hate
reading my movies but that ain't got
nothing to do with them being asian i
just hate reading movies there's great
german movies there's great italian
movies there's great spanish spanish the
spanish tv cinema that's coming out
right now it's great stuff but then you
gotta like have listen to the dub and
and you have to read and i don't like
doing that but i don't know it don't
take away from the greatness of
the product
i mean
all those like you know crouching tiger
hidden dragon uh what's the one about
the knives i mean there's some the
movies are beautiful they're shot great
the action is great and it's just like
you know
you know and then part of it is so all
right let me play devil's advocate to
myself i can understand like would we
just watch a regular movie like the
notebook and it's starring all asian
people
to me what would only stop me like i
said is the language barrier but in
terms of like the story it i i just i
wouldn't i just don't care now that what
i'm trying to say is it does kind of
suck that
when i'm talking about this
that kung fu element
has to be there for me it don't have to
be there but i i recognize that the ones
i'm talking about it's always that
there's something about that it's it's
like i romanticize it i love it
there's nothing better than like
you know
it's a dude whose family gets killed
and he has to avenge his family so he
goes and trains with a master and then
he like learns this thing he comes back
he avenges his family like a lot of that
a lot of the movies on black belt
theater were just that and then like
during the fights during the final fight
scene they always flash back to the
training so like let's say like he was
practicing to hit a log because they
always show this they're hitting a log
that he's like hitting the log and then
like in the training there's a when he
finally gets it he like hits the log and
the hog log shatters and then when it's
time to like you know during the final
fight scene he hits the person in the
chest and then they flash back to the
log shattering and then you know oh his
insides just shattered and you're like
yes he did it and it's like a lot of
movies are like that but uh but also
underneath that with the kung fu it's a
lot about love and honor and respect
like the asian cultures that they show
in these movies from the different you
know korean chinese japanese it's always
about honor and doing what's right it's
always about like honoring your father
and mother and like taking care of your
family and and those concepts i love all
of that
and i could care less
that the last thing me personally eric
griffin is looking at is even caring
about oh is it all asian oh man this is
all asian i don't know who wants to see
this and i tell you why too cause i'm a
person of color i've always had to look
at all white [ __ ] my whole life when i
was a kid it was like you know it's like
oh we have to look at you know and you
just go okay well we got to enjoy it so
if i want to look at entertainment this
is what i have to look at so when i see
something else i'm kind of like oh cool
this is good and that's how it always
was when i was a kid
you know it's like not listen there's
garbage of everything guys i've seen the
chat they go i've seen some garbage
asian stuff yeah there's garbage
everything there's you know what i mean
every every race culture every every
hollywood studio has put out a lot more
garbage than anything else but what i'm
saying is the stuff that i enjoy the
stuff that i look back and go this was
fantastic
this is you know
i never thought to myself it was because
they were asian or
or anything like that like the race part
of it never entered my mind it always
was about the art of it it always was
about like what's happening on the
screen and
and and what's happening between these
characters but that's just me so i do so
i'm triggered so when i hear this
nonsense you know to me it's nonsense
because it's just me my perspective yes
i know there are people out there that
hate there are some ignorant ass fools
out there i know this okay but i think
uh society the
twitter woke media they like to play
things up that's that's to play things
up for the sake of playing it up because
who are you helping who are you helping
but they were talking about banning this
like they were going to boycott this
movie because of cultural appropriation
and all this kind of stuff where i just
go what are you talking about man what
are you talking about what do you want
what do you want
you know people think that like
you should just put something out like
they want all these things to be in line
and they think that's entertaining
that's the funny thing too like y'all
dummies have forgotten
entertainment is the most important part
about this do people need to be
entertained people have to think like
they have to suspend their disbelief
and enjoy what they're watching
that doesn't mean that you have like
like and now we have to like make sure
every single person is the right race
and we have to make sure every single
it's like when you're doing all that
stuff to me you are taken away from the
art you're taking away from like it's
like when when a it's like an actor like
you have to be you know you have to be
whatever the per thing you're playing
you have to be that thing
so i can't pretend to be a plumber now
you you know we should hire a real
plumber to be an actor because you know
what about all the plumbers you're
taking away from and all that you know
that kind of like dumb sentiment and
it's like i get it i get one side of it
and at the same time i'm like yo man do
you know what the hell acting is this is
all pretend we're pretending to do
things you know and we're trying to
portray it that's the art the art is
being something that you're not that's
the whole art that is acting
that is acting
i'm getting worked up so
enough
uh
anyways
so
you know
[Laughter]
yeah let me let me remember i'm still
doing all this by myself so let me get
my uh oh [ __ ] come on what's going on
here man i could never hear it
it's like i can never find anything when
it's time to like you know when it's
time to like when it's time to get out
of here
you know but again wiggy will be back
when he's on vacation with his family
he
so
go visit his parents so but he'll be
back but anyways
all right guys
[Music]
that's another episode of riffing with
griffin
thanks for being here we did it live i
should probably have a schedule when i
do live episodes but it doesn't matter
you guys are going to come or you're not
going to come i want to thank everybody
for the super chats today that was
really fantastic i really appreciate
that
um
let me go to the viewer activity
uh
thanks for all those people
oh i can't see it now it's not there but
anyways thanks for that um make sure you
check out my schedule
um you know on eric griffin.com if you
want to see me i am coming to a city
near you uh very soon
you know coming to a city near you
i'm at denver this weekend 9th through
the 11th i'm going to be in boston 23rd
to the 25th
addison improv first to the third so
check out eric griffin.com for the links
to the tickets right there so i
appreciate you guys that want to come
watch me live and thanks for being here
every week uh if you're new you know
please subscribe share do all that great
stuff for me
and you know this has been roofing with
griffin man rhythm with griffin you know
thanks for being here and i will see you
next
week
riffin griffin